depuis le 18 janvier la salle patenôtre
de rambouillet s'est transformé en un
centre de vaccination
elle fait partie des 13 sites désormais
effective dans le département ce
vendredi 19 mars le président du sénat
gérard larcher a rencontré sur place les
acteurs de terrain l'objectif faire le
bilan de deux mois de campagne de
vaccination dans le sud yvelines
premier constat qui avait pas les
collectivités territoriales ci avait pas
les professionnels de santé
s'il n'avait pas un centre hospitalier
on voit bien que ce qui se passe ici ne
serait pas possible j ajoute que les
bénévoles à rambouillet plus de 5000
personnes ont pu être vaccinés
mais les élus locaux souhaitent que la
campagne s'accélère davantage nous le
savons la vaccination est le moyen le
plus certain pour éradiquer ce virus est
que nous avons besoin d'être entendus
pour assouplir la façon de vacciner de
façon à pouvoir vacciner en masse c'est
la tante de la population et ça nous
l'entendons tous les jours ce que j'ai
retenu ce matin c'est que si on ne
change pas si on ne fait pas évoluer la
méthode nous n'atteindrons pas
l'objectif que d'ailleurs le président
de la république a fixés et je pense que
c'est un objectif que nous devons avoir
en partage le gouvernement s'est fixé
comme objectif d'atteindre 30 millions
de personnes vaccinées à l'été dans le
département plus de 96 milles yvelinois
ont reçu une première injection